another day another tenth vlog coffee on
a Tuesday and blog port for me it's
about stories I'm drawn to art forms
that avail themselves of stories in the
development of character because I love
hearing about how people choose to get
along in their century or less of life
within stories there are Zahn reserves
on was that I find particularly
interesting because of their capacities
to illuminate certain parts of our
experience that we may be hiding from
ourselves
for example maybe we tell ourselves that
were free in control that there's a plan
or person guiding us that reality is
hard like a stone and no it's an
important function of fiction to tear
these things dance in this vein one of
my favorite genres is cyberpunk a
projection of post-modernism which is
itself a refutation of general theories
and drawing heavily on science fiction
cyberpunk is a reaction to the
information age the age of the personal
computer established in the work of
William Gibson's Neuromancer series
cyberpunk features the interaction of
high tech and low light as Lawrence
Pearson describes it classic cyberpunk
characters were marginalized alienated
loners who lived on the edge of society
in general a dystopic futures where
daily life was impacted by rapid
technological change and ubiquitous data
sphere of computerized information and
invasive modification of the human body
what makes cyberpunk so compelling I
think is that a lot of these things are
already prevalent the internet social
media artificial organs augmented
reality and most recently the Google
glass now that our future will become
dystopia well that's a stretch but this
is fiction and I don't think it's really
the point of science fiction to be
predicted there's a deeper level in
cyberpunk and I think that it's captured
best in the film Blade Runner I think
cinema is uniquely suited to cyberpunk
because it has the advantages of the
visual and auditory the neon moving
lights the lilting longing music of the
brilliant Vangelis I mean as soon as
that first note goes bad in the
brilliant score - Blade Runner before
the credits are even over you know
exactly what the movie is going to
convey here just take a listen
[Music]
gives me chills every time blade
runner's meticulous romanticization of
cyberpunk I think is key to
understanding its power I think that the
breakdown in the social order the
overload of information the sheer size
and incomprehensible 'ti of this kind of
dystopia appeals to an important part in
everyone it's the desire to surrender to
succumb to the quite apparent truth that
everything means nothing it's my idea
and I admit that it's a controversial
one that everyone furtively understands
that life is meaningless despite what
they profess to believe in public and
that a moderated submission to this
chaos is in fact profoundly healthy
keyword moderate cyberpunk allows us a
way into this part of ourselves
it reflects loneliness the evasion of
responsibility and the severe impotence
of man in the mouth of the universe it
makes chump set of scientists and
dogmatists alike and though it tears
down the walls i've built to protect
myself from the largeness of nihilism
it's at the same time a feeling of
loveliness as if I was listening to a
gentle song and when the note turned had
melted
thank you for staying with me through 40
weeks of vlogs it's been an amazing time
doing these if you haven't subscribed
please subscribe tell people about us we
want this community to grow and get
bigger and hopefully we can do a lot
more